[Musik]
du hast ja ganz schön zugenommen also
habe ich gewonnen
meine diät beginnen erst morgen also
macht dunumer keine sorgen das ist nicht
gut für dein gewicht denn sie doch mal
ein gesundes gericht du bist doch selber
nicht der dünnste allerhöchstens zu der
dümmste das schoko hab ich verliebt denn
du hast heute ausgedient alles klar
ich wollte es ja mitgeteilt aber weil du
so gierig bist es ist jetzt ganz für
mich allein
[Musik]
und wie ich das xxl schoko bomben
hergestellt habe das zeige ich euch
jetzt in meinem video das riesen schoko
bon schmeckt genauso wie das original
das hat mir jeder bestätigt der davon
probieren durfte und ich wünsche euch
jetzt ganz viel spaß beim zusehen
am ende des videos zeige ich euch auch
noch wie viel das ganze liegt die erste
hälfte des schoko bons benötigen wir 600
gramm weiße geschmolzene kuvertüre 500
gramm milchpulver 150 g gehackte
haselnüsse und ein esslöffel vanille
extrakt
[Musik]
dass wenn in der extrakt gebe ich mit in
die weiße kuvertüre das hebt noch mal
den geschmack und hinzu kommt dann das
milchpulver das sorgt zum einen für die
konsistenz damit es nicht so steinhart
ist und außerdem hebt das nochmal den
milchigen geschmack von den schoko bons
der kein milchpulver finden sollte der
kann auch einfach kaffee wasser nehmen
da das milchpulver geschmacklich aber
viel viel besser ist als café weißer
habe ich euch dann nochmal die
verpackung in die infobox verlinkt dann
wisst ihr auch genau wonach er suchen
könnte im supermarkt und sobald das
untergerührt ist geht es weiter mit den
haselnüssen
[Musik]
die gehackten haselnüsse dürfen auf gar
keinen fall in unserer masse fehlen denn
das ist der typische crash denen die
schoko bons mit sich bringen und wenn
ihr das auch schön untergehoben habt
dann ist die creme auch schon fertig
[Musik]
die masse ist noch sehr flüssig das
ändert sich aber sobald ihr das gab es
in den kühlschrank stellt jedoch habe
ich hier immer erst eine hälfte des
schoko bons zubereitet denn ihr wisst ja
sobald das ganze hat wird kann man das
nicht mehr in die formen gießen
also reicht die masse für genau eine
befüllung dieser halb iphone ich
verlinke euch das auch noch mal in die
infobox schreibe euch die maßen mit dazu
damit ihr das zu hause auch ganz einfach
nachmachen können
[Musik]
sobald die formen dann gefüllt wurde
einfach noch mal mit einer winkel
palette oder anderem werkzeug
glattstreichen und dann kommt das ganze
auch schon zum aushärten in den
kühlschrank
[Musik]
nach einer stunde ist die erste hälfte
des schoko bons auch schon fertig ist es
komplett ausgehärtet und so stütze ich
es aus der form läge das auch mein brett
und gäbe dass bis zur weiterverarbeitung
in den kühlschrank
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die zweite hälfte zu
bereiten und hier gehen wir genauso vor
wie beim ersten mal ich möchte also
nochmal alle zutaten zusammen gebe dass
in die form streiche es anschließend
glatt und lasse das noch mal für eine
stunde aus kühlen
[Musik]
falls jemand zwei dieser halb ein
förmchen hat kann er auch gerne parallel
arbeiten dann geht das ganze natürlich
schneller und meine hälften des schoko
bons sind jetzt komplett ausgekühlt und
ausgehärtet jetzt müssen wir sie nur
noch zusammensetzen
[Musik]
dafür eignet sich am allerbesten weiße
kuvertüre meine habe ich in einem
spritzbeutel umgefüllt vorne die spitze
abgeschnitten und gebe davon jetzt quasi
als kleber etwas auf die eine hälfte des
schoko bons
danach wird die zweite hälfte einfach
darauf gegeben und die schokolade klebt
die zwei hälften quasi wie von alleine
sobald die schokolade aushärtet kann da
auch nichts mehr passieren
ich gebe das hier an der stelle noch mal
für 20 minuten in den kühlschrank und
sobald die zwei hälften komplett
aneinander kleben verfolge ich quasi
noch die ränder damit das auch schön
glatt ist im endergebnis also hier
einfach noch mit weißer kuvertüre
nacharbeiten
[Musik]
nachdem auch das ausgehärtet ist geht es
weiter mit dem schoko bad und dafür habe
ich mich hier so eine art station
aufgebaut damit die kuvertüre auch
anschließend herunter fließen kann und
sie nicht auf dem tisch landet und hier
habe ich selbstverständlich voll mit
kuvertüre verwendet jetzt wird das ein
rundherum damit übergossen und dann ist
es auch schon fast fertig
[Musik]
nach dem aushärten sieht dass ein und so
aus es hat also unten noch keine
kuvertüre abbekommen das holen wir jetzt
ganz schnell nach indem wir das jetzt
noch mal in vollmilch profiteure trinken
und anschließend abtropfen und abkühlen
lassen
[Musik]
das war der vorerst letzte schritt
nachdem das dann abgekühlt ist können
wir auch schon ans wiegen gehen das darf
bei mir nie fehlen
und hier sehen wir ein kleines schoko
bonn das wiegt satte sechs gramm also
ist natürlich total schnell aufgegessen
davon hat man ja gar nichts und jetzt
zeige ich euch wie viel denn das xxl
schoko bonn liegt unser riesenschock
oben wiegt stolze 1791 gramm
und so wird das schoko man bei mir nun
eingepackt ich habe mir das schoko baum
logo auf weißem papier ausgedruckt gebe
das jetzt umgedreht auf durchsichtige
geschenk folie und passend dazu habe ich
noch zwei rote bänder
[Musik]
nachdem das schoko bonn in die folie
eingewickelt wurde schneidet den
überschuss ein wenig ab fixiert es dann
von hinten mit etwas tesa band und dann
nimmt die rote bänder und wickelt das
oben und unten wie ein bonbon 1
[Musik]
wenn die folie oben und unten so wie
hier im bild noch ein wenig zu lang ist
dann nehmt euch eine schere und
schneidet das gerne noch ein wenig
kürzer
und falls ihr jetzt noch jemanden kennt
der schoko bons genauso wie ich über
alles liebt dann ist das jetzt die
perfekte geschenkidee
[Musik]
ich finde dass das xxl schoko bon dem
originalen kleinen schoko bons in nichts
nachsteht wieder geschmacklich noch
optisch und hier seht ihr auch natürlich
nochmal den anschnitt falls euch das
video gefallen hat dann schaut euch doch
gerne meine anderen xxl rezepte an die
ich euch am ende des videos verlinkt und
ich freue mich immer sehr über eure
daumen hoch und über ein abo aufgenommen
es ist so oft gesagt hast mach mal
[Gelächter]
alles klar
nein alles klar
eigentlich wollte ich ja mitgemacht